but first up he represents California's
28th in the house where he is the
Intelligence Committee thanks for being
here thanks for thanks for a lot of
things thanks for keeping your sanity
are you keeping your sanity how you
holding up under all this what about you
doing okay thank you very much every day
a new adventure I'll bet it is so you
know I I sometimes watch the other
channels to see what they're saying
because we do live in two different
universes and when I see MSNBC or CNN
it's a lot about what you're saying
on Fox News the talking point is always
let's just wrap this up because after
all this time there's no there there
what do you say to the know they're
there people is there a they're there if
there was no they're there James Comey
would still have a job I think you know
what I think is so important to get
across about this because at the root of
this is why should people care about
this and as important as the collusion
issue is there's a lot at stake here
even beyond that and what people need to
recognize the Russians intervene not
just because they wanted to help Donald
Trump but not just because they hated
Hillary Clinton they interviewed because
they wanted to tear down our democracy
just as they wanted to tear down the
democracy in France with Marie lepen and
why they'd like to see Angela Merkel
defeated there is a real struggle of
ideas around the world of
authoritarianism versus democracy Putin
is leading the autocratic Vanguard and
has imitators in Cairo and Ankara Turkey
in the Philippines there's a run
struggle and you have a president nine
states loves dictator love's law use
authoritarian figures and you know
probably the most distressing headline I
have seen since the last endless hundred
and ten days was when Angela Merkel came
to visit the headline in Politico was
leader of the free world meets Donald
Trump right
and this was this was so painful in our
name for you and it's not only I think
disastrous for the United States
internally because he has provoked and
continued these terrible divisions in
our country but he is dimming the beacon
of hope for the rest of the world people
that are in prison because they
demonstrated in Tahrir Square and they
were the secular opponents of the regime
and people in the Philippines who lost
loved ones when they were murdered in
extrajudicial fashion they look to the
United States to speak for them and it's
a grave tragedy all over the world if we
lose that mantle leadership and that's I
think part of what's at stake why we
need to get to the bottom of what the
Russians did here what the Russians are
doing in Europe and how we fight back
and you know in a bizarre series of
weeks it seemed like this week was
stranger than even the ones that came
before because it did seem to me like he
may have admitted to committing a crime
he said that he they almost said word
for word that he fired call me because
the Russia thing in his opinion isn't
real
that seems like obstruction of justice
he also was asked did you ask Comey for
his loyalty and he said no I didn't but
that's a great idea it also was illegal
correct it is staggering plainly what he
did if you can believe him was at a
minimum unethical improper etc whether
it's illegal also depends on whether you
think he's telling the truth
ironically the most incriminating things
are if you believe him but of course
when it comes to Russia
you really can't believe what this
president is saying and here is you know
compounding that by saying you know
director Comey you better look out
because I may had tapes so is it worse
if he's telling the truth and he is
guilty of what he accused his
predecessor of wiretapping people in the
White House or is it worse that the
president adage we'll just willy-nilly
tell the American people of things that
patently untrue but if but if the
Republicans had on Hillary if she was
president now and said the same thing I
do feel that they would have drawn up
impeachment charges already I I worried
that the Democrats are still too nice
and I've asked Democrat about this
before well you know sometimes what
their answer is is we don't want to
stoop to their level to which I say yes
dupe a little you know what stooping in
the defense of Liberty is no vice well
and you guys really it's a bar fight is
all I think you're right
Democrats are too nice I'm too nice walk
alike but but but i likey what I mean
that'll I'll give you a German Shepherd
with beaten too much I'll give you a
perfect illustration of where we were to
nice and that is while the Russian
hacking operation was going on we knew
it was going on turnabout 2016 during
champagne during the campaign Obama knew
the president knew did I use it well the
president didn't come out early and
forceful and condemnation of what the
Russians were doing in fact senator
Feinstein I had to come out before our
own government was willing before the
administration was willing to attribute
the hack to Russia and here you had a
situation where Donald Trump candidate
Trump in July of last year is saying
openly never mind what his people might
be doing privately he's saying openly
hey Russia if you're listening hack
Hillary Clinton Singh rise you'll be
richly rewarded and and we're Democrats
fell down on the job in two ways one the
administration should have gotten out
there and condemn Russia and called for
sanctions then not after the election
but they were too worried I think about
being perceived as putting their hand on
the scale and we're all of us in the
Democratic Party fell down on the job is
we failed to persuade the American
people who largely knew what the
Russians were doing why they should care
and unfortunately more people and the
air should they excuse me why should
they hate Republicans this is treason
this is colluding with the enemy I mean
even what you just said about Donald
Trump inviting them to hack
if this was the shoe was on the other
foot they would not hesitate to use that
if they knew that the investigation was
going on as Obama would knew he didn't
say anything because he didn't even want
it to look bad well and when when he did
say something when the President did
that press conference I think he really
did put his finger on this and he was
marveling at just what you're saying how
is it that the party of Ronald Reagan
could allow condone a foreign
adversarial part party let alone Russia
intervene in our democratic writers and
his answer was look we have gotten to a
point where the partisanship is such
that for the party of Reagan it's okay
if Russian to intervene as long as it's
helped us the reason why the Russians
were successful is because we are so
bitterly divided and one of the reasons
is President is so destructive is he
keeps feeding those divisions and he
also keeps playing into the Russian
narrative that is behind the dismantling
of democracy and that is okay in Russia
we're not a democracy we're a thug ah
cracy we're a kleptocracy we don't make
any bones about it anymore but you know
something
America is - they're just a bunch of
hypocrites and we have a present United
States who goes on the may he rest and
television piece Bill O'Reilly's program
and he's asked yeah why can't you
criticize Putin the man's a killer and
his answer is are we so different that's
a lot of killers you couldn't write that
in Miller's rambling you couldn't write
write in the Kremlin any better
well how about having the Russians into
the Oval Office
I mean Kiselyov is their spy master in
this country he's got that Android phone
I'm not the first one to say this the
security people are saying that he's
still using the Android phone after they
hung her for using the wrong computer a
few times to send out wedding
invitations of whatever the hell was
going on there they probably already
well they probably already own them what
am I talking about I did it it really
mattered in the category of you can't
make this up which is the category we
live in now
right you have photographs of kiss lyac
and Lavrov would the president not
because
our own presses allowed in but because
the Russians take the pictures and 11
medias make this sale you're either with
us or with the Russians
remember Bush you are either with us you
know I will all I want to hear I will
tell you this if there was ever a time
in our history where the argument there
has to be a check on this executive we
need to change the Congress so there is
a Democratic House or Senate or both
because this president needs a restraint
that argument is now I feel like people
are making that argument we have some
footage of that Town Hall I mean people
are going to town holes now and yelling
at Republicans based on the Russia story
right we need a bipartisan select
committee to investigate this what are
you going to open your eyes we all see
it right dot you don't see what's going
on you don't see it whether you want to
decide to be an American and not a
politician
okay that's what I want you to sound
like how can make it after you in the
White House that's what they think I
sound like okay how can they got how can
they govern if that's what's brewing out
in America what are the Republicans
saying to each other behind closed doors
they must be [ __ ] their pants come
on well you know they say what it's in
my contract you can say it I can't I
know they they all want something from
this president before the wheels come
completely off the wagon they they want
their tax cuts they want their
regulatory repeal of the mining
regulations etc money and then they'll
find their spine right there are a few
people who are speaking out and I think
frankly this is John McCain's finest
hour
probably his most important public
service in Vietnam is what he is doing
now and I wish we had more Republicans
in the house or maybe even one in the
house who was willing to follow his
example
so I know back in March you said that
the case with the Russia of collusion is
more than circumstantial can you tell us
anything more and if you can't tell us
that can you tell us like when you
picture Donald Trump and say two years
what is he wearing
I I you know I'm all orange maybe I've
already made I'm already trying to get
the image of him in a bathrobe out of my
head right I all right I I you know I
don't know honestly where the
investigation will end up it's too early
to say it's a it's a mammoth undertaking
because it's global in reach
involves a lot of witnesses who may or
may not want to cooperate with us we're
working with a very small staff one of
the reasons why it's so important that
we oversee the FBI investigation and not
let that go or be impeded in any way
they have the scope they have the
resources they have thousands of agents
all across the globe there are things
they can do and must do that we can't so
part of our responsibility is doing our
own investigation and we are trying part
of our obligations to make sure the FBI
does the job they need to do all right
well there's nothing riding on this
except the First Amendment to the
Constitution freedom of the press and
maybe the fate of the country but if you
screw it up I'm going to get mad no
pressure all right Thank You congressman
keep doing what you're doing I know you
say shift everybody